this video is sponsored by surf shark
about 16 months ago i made the biggest
mistake of my career
bigger than that dreaded animated
moments video and bigger than my pokemon
video
those two were either naivety or lacking
in clarity but
this one i should have known better you
see 16 months ago i released a breakdown
of
the morrow character and the ark as a
whole before it's finished
on top of being largely negative i also
got so
so much stuff wrong so once i realized
all of this i made a promise to myself
that i wouldn't talk about the moral arc
until it finished up completely and
while i was waiting in silence you guys
sent me thousands and i mean
thousands of messages asking me to make
a video on it to rectify my mistakes and
to own
up to them and so with this video i'm
not going to do just that today i'm
going to write to you all about
why this is for me at this moment in
time the best dragon ball super arc in
the entire series
today i'm reviewing the very first manga
original story entitled
the morrow arc
[Music]
this year has been a roller coaster when
it comes to content with me exploring a
brand new story
in one piece and as a result it's been
literally seven
months since i've released or made
anything dragon ball related so
i thought what better way to end the
year than by returning to my roots in
reviewing the latest from the world of
dragon ball
and this one's rather special the arc
itself started in november of 2018 and
to be perfectly honest by the time this
one rolled around i was sort of
apprehensive to say the least toyotaro's
tournament of power didn't exactly set
my world on fire and with this new arc
to have the slate wiped completely clean
once again with another story out of
nowhere
with a little connection to the prior i
was really starting to feel tired of the
product overall
and thus were the feelings surrounding
my time with the manga for the months
and chapters that trickled on into 2019
and ultimately 2020 until i arrived
today with this video for you to say
that this story
is honestly way way better than i
thought it was and
easily my favorite in dragon ball
super's catalog and what's more is that
it
actually boasts a pretty simple story
goku and vegeta get recruited by the
galactic patrol to stop some bad guys
we're introduced to the galactic patrol
prison where
all the worst people in the universe are
kept except for frieza
it's here we also are introduced
tomorrow and after escaping from prison
he defeats goku and vegeta on namek
forcing them to do their own independent
training
while he becomes a more powerful younger
fighter
culminating in a massive battle on earth
and with
earth i swear it'll make sense later
until finally goku and vegeta alongside
the combined efforts of the planet's
inhabitants overpower and defeat
moro for good it's a simple story and
honestly has some surprisingly good
execution when you go
back over it and read it all at once
peppered throughout there's plenty of
interesting choices that honestly
remedied many of the transgressions of
the prior story arcs that more than
anything else
made this a joy to read through in
comparison this manga by toyotaro has
been in serialization since 2015
releasing one chapter every month since
however
starting with battle of gods through
universe 6 goku black and even the
tournament of power
akira toriyama has written the story for
the series and
a successor for lack of a better term
has assumed the responsibility of
bringing toriyama's vision to life in
the illustration department and his name
is toyotaro i've spoken about him in a
number of different videos and if you're
interested you can check them out too
but
to be brief going into this new act over
two years ago
i was extremely nervous for what was to
come not just because i had tremendous
issues with toyotaro's illustrations in
the past
but also because the production of this
arc would be unlike anything we've
received in the past
it would be the first story in dragon
ball super with the most direct
involvement from
toyotaro and while the story had some
minor issues here and there i
sincerely think this is the best story
in dragon ball super so without delaying
it any further
let's start at the very beginning and
break down what i thought of it
the introduction the intro to this arc
isn't particularly flashy but one aspect
i did think
it nailed is its build up to the
character of moro
starting with a cold open to recruit the
likes of vegeta and goku by the new
addition to the cast of this arc in
maris
we as viewers get to see flashbacks to
10 million years ago with the likes of
the lord of lords battling with moro
along with introducing us to the
expanded world of the galactic patrol in
terms of world building i
loved this aspect of these introductory
chapters as they further expand the
scope of universe
itself the new dynamics and explorations
through the ranks and day-to-day tasks
of the galactic patrol made for scenes i
was quite excited to see more of
specifically those concerning jocko
because while reading one piece over the
last year
i also took the time to blitz through
jaco's manga
and if you haven't seen it it's honestly
a delight it's one of the more recent
works from akira toriyama from a
paneling and illustration point of view
too
and thanks to that short story i was
able to really enjoy
jocko a lot more as a character in this
tale when i revisited it for this video
specifically
and speaking of characters a criticism i
had right up until the death of maris in
the manga was that i really didn't feel
connected to him as a character however
now having gone back over
everything i can happily say that i was
wrong not only does he get characterized
with this interesting
air of mystery surrounding his person
early on but he is
all over this story from the very first
chapter he is the inciting incident that
sparks the activities and introduces the
heroes to the rest of the main story's
world
but more on mirrors a little later
needless to say it's time to dive into
some of the major conflicts of the arc
as we follow moro having escaped from
prison with his eyes set
on namek the nanix section one of my
larger criticisms of this series has
been their implementation of the other
characters like piccolo
or perhaps more obviously vegeta it
feels
to me at least that after having gone
through all of super
toei akira toriyama and toyotaro never
really knew what to do with vegeta's
character itself
forcing him to relive these same tired
routines we've seen plenty of in the
original series
in one respect i can understand why from
the very moment vegeta was introduced up
until the very end of the series in
dragon ball z he was
designed to fulfill a very specific
purpose to undergo a change arc to cause
conflict and tension within the story as
a result
of that growth and to be honest he was
incredibly effective in that role
as someone who their favorite characters
are from dragon ball z and i'd wager a
sizeable chunk of folks will choose
vegeta very very early on and it's easy
to see why but now that his character's
initial purpose for lack of a better
term has been satisfied
what now well the obvious answer would
be to give him a new goal but that's
easier said than done you can't just
give him anything to do it needs to be
rooted in his character or
more specifically his history otherwise
it runs the risk of feeling extremely
artificial and
that's the last thing you want with a
character that feels so real so at the
very least i can empathize with the
struggles of the writing staff at toy
and akira toriyama at large they've
clearly been dealing with a lot
however thankfully this arc changed all
of that and not only gave vegeta a brand
new experience for us to see him deal
with but it was also rooted in his
character's history we've been there for
all of vegeta's transgressions after the
events of the saiyan saga we know
everything he got up to during that time
period on namek and thereafter and so
was now revisiting namek for the very
first time since becoming a more
complete character we not only see
vegeta feel shame for having committed
the things he's done
not only act in a positive way to enact
change but to also without flinching
accept and own up to his past
acknowledging that it's something he
needs to atone for leading to some of
the most compelling motivations in
all of dragon ball super that i've seen
culminating in him diving in before goku
to save a small namekian boy called
esca we've seen the character of vegeta
accept love into his life before
to accept friendship and to fight for
those people time and time again it
doesn't need to be brought to the
forefront like a pivotal moment for his
character anymore he's grown
past it and in this moral arc this scene
with vegeta interacting with the
surviving namekians fighting on behalf
of them and
losing really felt like something that
was destined to take place in the
original series
nothing about it felt artificial it's
easily one of my favorite aspects of the
story with these specific motivating
factors being informed by the past and
influencing the path vegeta takes
in this story this desire to pay this
debt he owes to this people
this noble act to him is the very trait
that leads him down the road to train
with the ardradians later on
on their behalf this new maturity
specifically makes him not only a
stronger person mentally but physically
as we
soon will find out it's also during this
sequence we learn more about moro as a
character but more specifically how he
fights
and boy did this impress me in a major
way
ignoring the fact that his magic is
visually stunning and unlike anything
you've seen from dragon ball in the past
morrow's set of powers is the perfect
remedy to one of the biggest
issues i had with dragon ball and maybe
even shonen at large
what i am specifically talking about is
something called power
creep you see eventually after the
frieza saga the strength of the
characters started to leave the realms
of imagination
and onto stages that literally encompass
the worlds of god's fighting
every subsequent challenge met by goku
and the gang as a result needed to be
met by stronger and more imposing
villains than they last encountered in
order for it to be worthwhile
it's one of the weakest aspects of long
running shonen if it's not planned in
advance it can seem contrived that
there's always
someone randomly stronger to fight
against and that can get tiring as it
usually results in goku needing to punch
him hard to fix it which
this moral arc has a lot of but what
makes it different is that unlike the
prior arcs where goku vegeta's strength
make it remarkably unbelievable that
they could ever find someone to
challenge their godly powers
it's that very energy that strength
they've cultivated to make morrow so
dangerous because
just by being around him he absorbs
their strength turning what was a
glaring weakness of the series into a
strength for the villain and i thought
that was brilliant leaving goku and
vegeta totally and completely drained of
energy on their first outing
on the verge of death leaving more to
wreak havoc on the rest of the namekian
people
as they recover building him up as this
imposing monster of a foe
complete with a fresh new design unlike
anything in the series
no transformations here folks just tons
of visual indicators that this eater of
worlds moro
is reaching a new level of strength with
each passing second forcing goku and
vegeta to retreat
they lost and now they need to do
something about it
the training arc having spent most of
this year covering a story that didn't
have a focus on training in general
i sincerely found it refreshing watching
goku and vegeta lick their wounds after
the events of namek
and go on their own separate ways to
train for me these trainiacs while
offering some nice training sequences
demonstrate the growth of each character
i think by far and away the most
interesting of these has to be vegeta's
training on yardrat on top of visiting a
location we've only ever heard of in the
original series
seeing the place felt equal parts new
and nostalgic
like it really belonged there which is
not something i can save for everything
in dragon ball super these days
while this training is taking place
however another parallel storyline
concerning morrow and a secret
wish arises and this becomes the talk of
the online community
for months you see in the closing
moments of the namek section morrow
manages to get his hands on not only
all of the dragon balls but he manages
to get his wishes for said balls on
namek this personally i thought was
exceptionally interesting as to my
recollection i hadn't ever seen a scene
like this before in the series
and what's more is toyotaro decided to
dangle moro's final wish like a carrot
in front of us by keeping it secret
twitter instagram reddit and youtube
were set ablaze
theories were firing left right and
center it was so cool watching the
fandom speculate over something so
vigorously regarding dragon ball
i mean the possibilities seem endless
and then
it was revealed that the surprise was
well
he wished for the prisoners to be
released from the galactic prison
whoa some fodder for the secondary
characters
or at least that's what i thought and
just like that all these months of
speculation went down the drain it was
disappointing
why are you the way that you are but you
know what's funny
going back over this arc all at once
this didn't bother me
nearly as much which brought something
interesting to my attention
this story is remarkably simple but it
felt
really long at 25 chapters if you
include the ending chapter of the
universe survival arc featuring miris
despite being the fifth story are
covered in the dragon ball super manga
it
accounts for over 37 of the total
chapters in all of the series
now that's not to say 25 chapters itself
is long i mean
please i've read about a thousand
chapters of one piece this year but
what made this story feel long and at
times strange to follow was
its release and production schedule you
see with the classic dragon ball manga
by akira toriyama in the 80s and 90s
readers in japan got to experience the
story not once a month
but every single week with the chapters
being shorter the story as a result had
to be structured such that every 11 or
so pages
there would be a cliffhanger to end that
week's release chapter
this is in part why i believe dragon
ball z was so infectious and so well
paced
in the manga uh he's not the anime
a chapter would be released every single
week creating routine and for those
binging it
every 11 pages there will be something
to encourage them to read on if you've
ever held a dragon ball manga in your
hand you'll know exactly what i'm
talking about open a random page and
you'll get sucked in
immediately the thing's infectious so
what does this have to do with the moral
arc of super
well in classic dragon ball 25 chapters
would usually translate to about five
and a half months worth of content
in super it translated to over two years
and when you get a cliffhanger once
every month if the particular chapter is
uneventful which some of them genuinely
are it makes it so easy to forget about
this series and the specific events
therein
if something bugs you about this story
you now have a month to be bothered by
it
whereas had it a more regular release
scheduled the weaker chapters wouldn't
hang around
very long anyway speaking from my own
personal experience there have been
months where i genuinely forgot the
manga was being released had i not had
twitter for you guys to remind me i
legitimately would have been months
behind at this point
it's a small criticism and maybe i'm
nitpicking but from a scheduled release
standpoint
i sincerely don't believe enough story
gets covered in the manga month to month
to warrant this sort of release schedule
comparing it to series like attack on
titan that releases monthly also
the difference in how much story is
covered per monthly chapter is honestly
staggering
and so given all of that my first
negative critique of this arc
actually has nothing to do with the
story but in fact it's serialization
release schedule and as a result that
one secret wish morro made
while it was a blip in the overall story
being told it was
at the forefront of fans minds for
literally
months allowing them to build false
anticipation
had this been released weekly like the
classic dragon ball audience
expectations could have been managed
much much more efficiently and going
back over this series this moment comes
and goes so fast
it honestly doesn't even feel like it's
worth talking about but i digress
[Music]
i want to thank surfsharkvpn for
sponsoring today's video
in the ocean of online content there's a
lot of websites that take your info
without you even knowing it but you can
swim under their radar using
surfsharkvpn with this particular
service you can stop websites from
tracking your info and selling targeted
ads to you online
completely protecting your privacy
nothing is creepier than when you have a
conversation with a friend about
something and it pops up in your ads
plus with surfshark hardlock id
protection you'll even get
alert when some rando jerk is trying to
break into your email but one of my
personal favorite features of surfshark
is that you can see content that's not
available in your area
for instance did you know that right now
on netflix you can have the first 130
episodes of one piece well
if you live in a country where that's
not available you can just log in with
surfshark and you can get access to that
or
any other show or film that that isn't
normally available for you
so if you want both freedom and
protection online click the link in the
description
and use code tnm it not only gives you a
whopping 84
off the regular price but also four
months of service
totally for free surf shark also offers
a 30 day money back guarantee so there's
no risk to even try it out for yourself
so if this service sounds interesting to
you or you want to support the channel
please
check it out now back to the video
it's the green let that child along
when it came to this section of the
story something that immediately stood
out to me while i was reading month to
month
was that finally we were getting
multiple points of view rather than
following the same isolated linear path
for the entire tale if you cast your
minds back to the namic and frieza sagas
of dragon ball z for example the point
of view wouldn't stay on gohan and
krillin ducking and dodging the frieza
force the entire time we got goku
training
king kai's planet vegeta's perspective
and not to mention frieza's among many
others dotted throughout this is
something that adds richness to the
world and
most importantly keeps pivotal plot
points interesting if you spend too much
time
somewhere then it starts to get boring
this was something super struggled
a lot with in my opinion but this arc
breaks that trend and successfully
establishes and utilizes multiple
different scenes
running parallel to one another we got
goku training with marist that
while brief at least establishes a nice
relationship between the two
we have vegeta training on yardrat
attempting to cast his pride to the side
to repay a debt in learning a new
strange technique this scene in
particular acts as a mystery box for
earth and in addition to those two
scenes we have the point of view of the
gods with whis
beerus and the grand priests but perhaps
most compelling of all we have a massive
conflict brewing down on earth as
morrow begins to move in with his
henchmen the battle for earth
it's at this point in the story my
excitement was honestly building quite
substantially
i recognized how interesting maura was
as a character in helping remedy the
power creep issue and
i also noticed the concurrent storylines
running all together knowing full well
that they would all converge on the
battle for earth eventually i was really
excited to see how things would unfold
as the two strongest in the universe
vegeta and goku eventually finish up
their training and make their respective
saves
but the question was to me at least
between goku and vegeta
who would make this save on who and to
my surprise as the z
fighters were defending the earth goku
arrives first
leading myself and many others to be
excited in seeing vegeta eventually
making the save on goku this was again
something we weren't too used to seeing
from vegeta and to say we were all
anticipating it
was an understatement once again this
was a situation where the entire
community was talking about it finally
goku would be saved by vegeta prior to
this much of the time on earth had been
spent with the likes of gohan piccolo
and the androids as they overcome the
interesting and bizarre henchmen of moro
establishing for us
a pecking order and the means with which
moro has been harvesting energy across
the universe however once they realize
that they vastly underestimated the
forces of earth
more and more fighters start to pour in
leading to them eventually being
overwhelmed until
goku shows up to save the day and save
the day he most certainly does
taking out the individuals that have
been causing the most trouble quickly
eventually coming face to face with the
goat man himself
moro for me the interest behind this
particular fight stemmed from the prior
battle where goku was
well i mean he was dominated on top of
that we know full well that moro has
become
even more powerful since but perhaps at
the forefront of everyone's minds at
this point would be the fact that goku
has been training with maris who has
revealed himself to be
an angel in training and together their
training consisted of maris trying to
acclimatize goku to use
ultra instinct on command and while they
found
some success the form was still
unrefined only managing to reach ultra
instinct's sign
however now he can control it so
that's something at least looking more
abstractly for a second there are a
variety of elements that make up this
story taken from
various parts of the original dragon
ball storyline morrow's search for power
and youth bears striking similarities to
king piccolo's saga the dynamic this
ultra instinct sign
introduces in this specific battle is
very similar to that of the kaioken
technique used during the frieza saga
goku isn't going all out at first but
even after he does it's still not enough
and all the while it drains him off his
energy and stamina
and perhaps my favorite similarity of
this story comes by way of a role
reversal which in all honesty is fitting
considering this journey vegeta has
specifically undergone in this arc
after having spent quite some time
training alongside the likes of the
ardradians vegeta arrives using a
signature technique of his rival
at the last second to make the save on a
downed goku after his initial fight with
moro and
it's thematically fitting too this arc
has made it its mission to drive home
the fact that vegeta is a different
person now and regrets having committed
the atrocities he did on namek way back
when
those events and choices he made on
namic led him to where he was before
frieza
beaten defeated and crying all the while
goku shows up to make the save at the
very last second
however now things are different armed
with a new technique and a virtuous
motivation
vegeta has not only told us through
context clues and dialogue but in a very
real way has shown us by reversing his
position in this very instance
he is no longer the one being saved he
is the one that arrives to save the day
this is one of my favorite moments not
just in this arc but honestly
the series it's a great moment for
vegeta unfortunately
this greatness is short-lived as it's
quickly followed by some of the most
ham-fisted dialogue i've ever seen in
dragon ball
there's this sequence where piccolo
turns into a youtube video essay channel
and begins deconstructing the
character telling us what he means to
people and what he's done for them
within the confines of a story this
doesn't need to be spelled out to the
audience something like this feels right
when it's unspoken but when it's spoken
it feels like he's winking at the camera
everyone knows what he means to the rest
of the cast and so should goku
but in this scene stupid super goku
makes his return and blissfully nods
along before acknowledging that he has
no idea what piccolo was even talking
about in addition to that piccolo also
makes note that vegeta isn't one to
underestimate his opponent
why are you the way that you are this in
addition to a couple of other minor plot
contrivances make up the low point of
this arc for me
if this arc ever gets adapted into an
anime please for the love of all that is
holy please remove these ridiculous
sections
sidestepping those bad bits for now
let's talk visuals because there are
some
genuine improvements from the older arcs
now as many of you know i have not been
the biggest fan of toyotaro's paneling i
think oftentimes he relies too much on
large numbers of panels too many speed
lines and takes an approach to depicting
his stories that more closely resembles
a storyboard for an anime than an actual
manga making full use of its medium and
despite much of what i've just spoken
about being present in the latest
material
i am not afraid to say that i've seen
some marked improvements that i enjoyed
too
from some really wonderful full and
double page spreads a less cluttered
approach to his paneling in places
and an abundance of gestural drawings
for the various characters in battle oh
my god let's go
it really helped to bring this story to
life for me and in ways prior arcs under
his control had not in other words from
a visual point of view this manga is
trending up in a direction i think is
favorable for the series at large
and that makes me happy oddly enough
however while i appreciate the
significance that this
new move vegeta brings to the table from
a lore standpoint i think
visually it looks extremely unimpressive
this
normally wouldn't bother me too much but
we're talking about dragon ball here the
show that popularized the kamehameha
mesenko kamehameha
and countless other important and
visually interesting techniques
however force spirit fission as it's
called really
looks boring which honestly i think is a
shame this move i can see being a
massively important component
to later arcs in the series too so it
sucks that it's not cool to look at
at least not for me and finally an
aspect i really didn't like from a
visual standpoint was the final powerful
form moro takes in response to vegeta
and goku's efforts on him having sealed
away his power in another interesting
being called 7-3
moro literally eats him regains all his
lost power that was taken by vegeta's
four-spirit vision and
he just looks like a weird version of
cell now while i didn't think the goat
form of moro looked particularly dragon
ball
i at least thought it looked distinct in
that form morrow had his own identity
but
this version of him just looks like that
homework you copied from a friend
right before class started you know what
i'm talking about you change it just
enough so that it doesn't look like you
completely copied the guy
so yeah visually i'm not a huge fan of
this but despite this however
what this means in terms of the
narrative is clear morrow is back to
full power and vegeta and goku
are spent forcing maris to break the
rules of the angels helping in an effort
against moro damaging him prominently
before vanishing completely into thin
air the character of maris is honestly
one i adored in this story the idea of
an immortal being an angel in training
grappling with the morality and ethics
of his individual situation
not knowing whether or not what he has
been told to do is
just forced to make this difficult
decision he chooses to do what he
perceives to be the right thing
despite death being the consequence it's
a touching moment and one that is made
much more powerful if you go back and
read it all in one go
month to month i totally forgot so much
about maris as a character
and when i went back the second time it
was so so much better
i might sound also like i'm harping on
about different character moments here
and there but honestly this arc is
filled with them
immediately after this goku rallies
himself from the ground fueled with
motivation after maris passes on and has
a really nice interaction right before
his fight with moro
as he speaks with jocko asking him why
he joined the galactic patrol and it's
quiet moments like these that really
added so much more flavor and texture to
the story again
something that the other acts of super
lacked in my opinion what follows this
however is a really nice beat down at
the hands of goku wielding the full
power of ultra instinct
once again there's some really nice
artwork on display and in addition to
there being
some interesting back and forth
including an unfortunate cell saga
callback regarding a senso bean and a
downed morrow the best part of the final
act for me is the cooperation between
vegeta and goku there's some crazy stuff
like moro turning into the earth and
goku attaining the avatar state which
okay i get it sounds like it's coming
out of nowhere and it's kind of silly
and
okay it's kind of silly but it
definitely doesn't come out of nowhere
this is actually a really subtle
callback to something that happened way
back towards the beginning of the arc
itself by the arduino elder in this
brief section he discusses how it's a
link or harmony between your body and
spirit and if that's not enough
during that very section too he fooled
vegeta into thinking himself to be
massive
when in actuality he's not and given
that ultra instinct satisfied
all of those parameters it stands to
reason that goku would be able to use it
too specifically because he must have
been made aware of the technique as he
already
spent a lot of time on yard drag and so
something that was thought to be silly
actually turns out to be a really nice
callback that completely took me by
surprise so much so that
i actually completely forgot about it
when i was reading month to month but
again when i was reading it straight
forward
start to finish binging it it made so
much more sense
culminating with vegeta helping goku
form a spirit bomb fueled by the most
unlikely of characters
adding even further build up to a moment
we all know is coming in the future
with boob overall loved this decision
personally
the last chapter the last chapter of the
morrow arc provided for me something
i've been waiting for since the original
dragon ball story ended after the buu
saga
something that the super series has been
sorely lacking
has been finally addressed a
cohesiveness that was present in all of
the original material that allowed it to
feel like one massive story rather than
individual smaller segmented ones
is now present in super in some regard
you see in z
raditz flowed naturally into the vegeta
fight which flowed again actually into
the frieza fight and so on
in super the battle of god's story has
nothing to do with the resurrection f
material
which has nothing to do with universe 6
stuff and for the future trunks saga
there has been a massive void from the
storytelling department
present since the series rebirth back in
2015 and now
for the first time in the revamp i can
say categorically that this one flows
into the next story making it instantly
more interesting
in ways that i can't even begin to
comprehend alone in this one paragraph
there's even a scene that gives actual
consequences to the actions of the prior
chapters
miros gave himself up and in the process
vanished a quick fix for this usually
would have been the dragon balls or for
the gods fixing this and while he is
brought back
he lost his angel abilities and is now
mortal that's a large consequence for
that character and while not massive
compared to the other stories
it is at least for dragon ball
significant i am more than ready to
launch into this next story of the
dragon ball series with toyotaro at the
helm now and i'm excited to see this new
wonderful character being introduced
this granola character sports a really
nice design i love the hair and the
artificial body attachments
and beyond anything else i love that he
has a vested interest in the recovery of
7-3
after his battle on earth it's connected
it makes sense
and it's compelling it's all very
exciting and i'm so interested to see
what more is to come and despite coming
away from certain chapters disliking
what i perceive to be
cheap callbacks and unoriginal takes on
a tenuous story at best
upon rereading the ark for the sake of
this video i was so surprised to see how
little those negative nuggets mattered
when i could immediately venture forth
onto the next chapter
taking instances like morrow looking to
get young again feeling like king
piccolo or goku giving moro a sense of
being feeling like the cell games when i
finished reading this story i was able
to put those isolated instances to the
side and enjoy the story for what it was
last year i wrote a review i am honestly
embarrassed by
and i hope that this review at least
helps to write that wrong the moral arc
while there are hiccups here and there
is easily the best arc pinned by
toyotaro to date implementing narrative
choices i've been waiting literal
years for and now that we've gotten a
glimpse of this new strikingly modern
toriyama design for granola
it's clear to see that dragon ball super
has potentially a very bright future
ahead of it if they can keep the
standard up
beyond the currently discussed stories i
love dragon ball
i always will and i can't wait to see
what the series has to offer in the
future
but until then i've been totally not
mark
i'll see you all in the new year and
thank you all so much for watching
[Music]
hmm
you